do I look like I just woke up it's
because I did this morning I wake up to
give you guys gifts of information
knowledge is the only true power in the
world by that I'm giving you power I
mean how awesome is that aren't you glad
you subscribed so this morning I wake up
to a text from my friend saying holy
[ __ ] kratos is going to be playable in
mortal kombat and initially i think yeah
right so i look into it sure enough
seems pretty legit i'm going to say it's
a strong rumor right now because every
time i come out and say that something
is some studio douchebag make some
public statement saying is actually not
true we didn't fire the writers of
walking dead so today to you guys i giv
v-- news or strong rumor that supposedly
kratos from god of war is going to be
playable in mortal kombat which i think
is awesome because that's like kratos is
element that's perfect I mean he's been
in fighting games before he was in that
Soul Calibur game for the PSP portal
combat that's some gratuitous violence
that is Kratos his element right there
now a couple of things one he's not
going to be playable in the story mode
he's just in vs. mode and - he is
PlayStation 3 exclusive him being a Sony
character and also Xbox people I'm sorry
you'll probably get someone to though
I'm expecting Master Chief or John
Madden and supposedly he's gonna have
his own fatalities which is how you do a
crossover I mean come on Sony's like
yeah you can kill our guy as long as he
can kill you too
unlike the Mortal Kombat vs. DC thing
where it's like mr. Superman can't kill
people is just certain Oh neither can
Batman Green Lantern can crush you with
his ring now that's ok I just will not
have done it so killing people with the
blades of chaos we've all done it a few
times over but I mean come on
killing Chang soon like that something
awesome about that so - this suppose
it's strong rumor which I for one hope
is absolute fact what do you guys think
about this Kratos in the Mortal Kombat
game perfect how can you not say is
perfect but what about Xbox who do you
think they're gonna get if they're going
to get anyone and should they get
someone don't be biased Xbox is a
console - comment below let me know
triclosan Mortal Kombat's like a perfect
marriage really but if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more